Fate isn't something that someone decides No,
that's what Nardo himself taught me.
Not being used,
and losing my father,
all of which I had given up on the fate of being a branch family that I couldn't escape from by birth
.
I'm bad at giving up
1.
Why are you trying to go against your destiny?
I'll dare
to try Kou-chan and Uncle Neji
even now Naruto is still fighting against fate A
lonely and harsh fate that has dangerous powers in his body from birth Even a terrible fate that he
might kill each other with his friends That
kind of thing  Hey
[music]
You talk a little too much about what I did.
I don't need anything It
's only natural
to be afraid of the power you know
so well  I wish I had